[موسيقى]
بعد اسبوعين من انسحابها من مقاطعه خيرسون
تعود القوات الروسيه الى تركيزه هجومها
على المقاطعه التي تعرضت لقصف مكثف استهدف
اكثر من 23 قريه على طرفي نهر النيل برو
وذكر الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه
قصفت المقاطعه تسعه واربعين مره خلال
الساعه الماضيه وفي نيكولايف تحدثت سلطات
المدينه عن قصف روسي استهدف منشات البنيه
التحتيه الخاصه بالمياه والكهرباء كما
استهدفت المدفعيه الروسيه مدينه نيكول
الواقعه في مقاطعه بعشره القذائف وفقا
للجيش الاوكراني وعلى الجانب الروسي اعلنت
السلطات المواليه لروسيا في مقاطعه دونيت
سقوط قتلى وشرح قصف الاوكراني في الساعات
الماضيه كما اعلنت موسكو توجيها ضربات الى
نقاط ينتشر بها من سمتهم مرتزقه بولنديين
في مقاطعه خا في الشماليه اوكرانيا
وبالتوازي مع احتدام القتال بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه يوصل حلف شمال
الاطلسي بعث رسائل داعمه لكيف مفادها عدم
تراجع دول الحلف عن تسليم اوكرانيا ما
يمكنها من التصدي للقوات الروسيه
معظم الحروب تنتهي بمفاظات لكن ما يحدث
على طاوله المفاوضات يعتمد على ما يقعوا
في ميدان المعركه ولذلك فان افضل السبل
لتعزيز فرص التوصل الى حلف سلمي دعم
اوكرانيا فنيته سيواصل تضامنه مع اوكرانيا
ما استغرق ذلك من وقت
الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي وصف الدعم
المقدم الى كيف بغير المسبوق وانه سيطلب
المزيد من الدعم وسط تمديد دولي على
استهداف القوات الروسيه للبنيه التحتيه
الحيويه وهو ما وصفته المندوبه الامريكيه
لدى الامم المتحده بالتصعيد المخجل في حرب
وحشيه غير مبرره